Hello everybody, I hope that you're
good. I hope that you're having a nice
end of the year.
At this time of the year, I like to
start to set some goals for the year to
come, for 2026, because doing it this
way, I'm not relying on motivation that
sometimes it can last me a week, 1 month
maybe, but not a whole year.
Motivation doesn't last that long, you
know? It comes and goes. And I do think
that, you know, focusing on goals is a
much more consistent way and and more
reliable to I get you, you know, achieve
your goals. So, I recommend you to do
the same. Set some goals for next year.
One of mine is to be more consistent
with this YouTube channel. Let's see if
I can do so. I'll try my best.
Because I do think it's a very nice way
to communicate and I can explain my
ideas in in a much better way. But
anyway, in this video, we're going to be
talking about what I'm expecting for
Bitcoin for the next, you know, 1 2 3
weeks, short term. All right? And I do
think that we're going to see a lot of
volatility. I'm going to start with
that, okay? I'm going to explain to you
why. So,
if I get this chart over here,
this is going to get a bit technical.
So, I'll try my best that you can
understand it in simple terms.
But this chart here
is talking about the gamma flush, okay?
What is the gamma? The gamma basically
is how many options are expiring, okay?
Let's say that when there are many
options open in the market, then it
forces market makers to hedge their
positions, okay? Because they are
trading the opposite of what the retail
trader does. So, the market maker needs
to keep hedging all the time. That means
that when price goes up, you know,
market maker needs to sell. When price
goes down, market maker needs to buy.
It's all the time hedging. So, when that
happens, you know, all you have is a
very boring range. Because the market
maker is not letting
any breakout
or break down to happen, okay?
Because it needs to keep hedging those
calls. Now, what is telling me this
chart is that, you know,
they are going to expire a lot of
options
today, December 26th. 46.2%
are expiring today. Now, you can see how
a week ago, already 20% expired.
And in total, if you put these two
numbers together, that's, you know,
exactly 66.
point
8%.
Okay?
Of all
the the options.
Okay? That's a lot. That's a gamma
flush. Now,
let's think that, you know, all these
options open here, forcing the market
maker to to establish a range, is kind
of, you know, when you put a lid
on a on a bottle. So, you know, you're
not letting the water to come out.
You are not letting the volatility to
come out, you know? You are kind of
blocking the volatility. But with 66.8%
of gamma leaving,
that is pretty much what I tell you
that there is going to be a lot of
volatility coming to the market.
All right? So,
that's pretty much what I'm trying to
tell you with this chart, that
expect some volatility from today.
And it pretty much explains why there
has been, you know, such a boring price
action.
And also, as I explained, December 10th
is this candle here,
which saw a a 12% drop within a few
minutes. Something happened that day. Um
Some information I got is that, you
know, some market makers got caught in
the volatility
and they had losses. So, they had to be
selling from around these levels here.
They've been selling to rebalance their
portfolios and now they should start, in
my opinion, to buy.
So, that's what I don't see very likely
that price is going to go
to the next support level. That, by the
way, we can set it here. It is very
clear the next support level is in this
area. You can see that's a very strong
support at 72,000 or 72,500,
all right? So,
obviously, if price it breaks below
this low here that we have at
80,000,
if it breaks below it
and it stays below it, that is telling
you that price should go lower, but I do
think that is not very likely based on
that information, okay?
I do think that it's more likely that we
sweep those lows.
Like this is a scenario that we have
here, that sweep of the lows, then go
back above it, retest it as a support,
and then that's when price can go up,
okay? That's one a scenario. That's one
trigger I have, very simple. And as you
can see,
um it's a scenario that I've been having
here for quite some time.
And so far it's been playing pretty
well, you know? This high would be this
one that is touching the local high at
94,500.
Then you have here another pump.
We could say that is what has happened
recently.
And soon,
with all the volatility volatility
coming, we should also be prepared for
this scenario, okay? That it's a lower
drop back, you know, retest all those
lows from the 21st of November at
80,000. If that happens and we see that
sweep of the lows, that retest,
and and price manages to get back above
it, confirm that that was a deviation,
I think that'll be an excellent swing
trade idea, okay? So, consider that as
an option. Be open to any scenario
because there is going to be a lot of
volatility over the next few days.
Okay?
And the other scenario, very simple,
guys, and is that, you know,
if Let me remove this.
I'm sure you've seen it in the
thumbnail,
but obviously is that if price manages
to go up from here,
I'm not going to trade this move, okay?
I'm missing out this move. I'm only
going long in if price sweeps the lows
of 80,000, these local lows, or I'm long
in if price goes up from here, gets
above this local resistance
that you can see has been plunging
price, you know, setting up into a range
for
a month, okay? But if price gets back
above this local resistance and test it
as a support, that's to me an idea for a
long, okay?
To the high time frame resistance. So,
pretty much 94,000 to 100k psychological
That is to me a nice uh
day day trade idea, okay? It's not much
of a of a swing trade really, because
there is not that much distance. It's
maybe a 6 7 8% of price move.
Because then here, obviously, at 100k,
I'm expecting a lot of resistance. You
can see
here,
one touch, two, three.
And obviously, all of that consolidation
there.
Four hits
at 100k. Also, it's a psychological
level. I'm expecting that there is a lot
of sell orders already placed there.
And that could be a bit of a wall, let's
say. So, yes, 100k should be a strong
resistance. But anyway,
um just to summarize,
breaking above 94,000,
and I'll open a long to 100k, or
retesting
and sweeping the lows of 80k, and that's
also where I'm opening a long, okay? And
then I'm expecting price goes back up to
94k. So, those are to me my two triggers
for long positions. Now,
let's have a look at Hyblock Capital.
Let's see how the liquidity is.
When I have Hyblock Capital, this is
what I look at the liquidity data. And
this chart is the liquidation levels. I
only look at two things in this chart.
One thing is the delta. You have it here
at the bottom of the chart, this red
mass that we see. And right now it's not
giving us much information. The only
thing it's telling us is that there are
more shorts than longs open at the
moment, but the difference is tiny, you
know, 700 million. That is nothing.
This is max liquidity setting. The
numbers are not real. They are
exaggerated, but it gives us some
um idea of what is happening.
In my opinion and for what I've seen
with my own eyes and experience, is that
when we get more than 20 25 30 billion
of
delta in the delta of difference between
shorts and longs or longs and shorts,
that is giving you a clear signal of a
of a squeeze, okay? But right now we
don't even have a 20th
of that, all right? So, irrelevant. It's
not giving us any information. Now, what
is giving us information is that the
highest
the the levels with the highest
liquidations, the most liquid levels in
the chart, those levels that, you know,
if they were to get hit, the market
maker would absorb the most liquidity,
is to the downside,
85,000. Well, exactly is 85,700.
And also, 87,500,
okay? Those two levels have a lot of
liquidity.
Also, to the upside we have three
levels, but with less liquidity, 89,600.
Then we also have
89,940.
So, let's say 90k. And 91.3k,
91,300, okay?
So,
my conclusion of this chart is that, you
know, dumping price to 70 87.5k
and also to 85k.7,
that will release a lot of liquidity
into the market. So, be open about the
idea
of the chart that I showed you, okay? Be
open to the idea that price could, so,
you know, maybe we don't see the famous
Santa rally and instead what we see is
some kind of a liquidity grab to
um
mid to low 80s first, and then price
could go up. We want to see the same in
this chart. These are the liquidation
heat map
in low time frame and you can see
exactly the same thing. A lot of
liquidity around 91k and to the downside
86k and 85k. Okay, that's the what we've
seen. So,
you know, if price
could be going up
is it possible that it goes down first,
absorbs that liquidity and then, you
know, that move to the upside could be
more efficient? That's what I'm
thinking, all right, at this
stage of the market. And then
in the high time frame liquidations, you
can see that really the liquidity is to
the upside, as we said, 95k.
So, that's what I mean. 95k in high time
frame to the upside and in low time
frame maybe to 85k. So, perhaps 85k or
even lower first
and then price could go up to that 95k
level
that it's also our local resistance,
remember, in a much more efficient way.
That's kind of my main scenario at the
moment, although
I'm staying with my two triggers.
Either give me a sweep of the lows of
80k, 80-81k, give me that retest and,
you know, price could bounce from there.
I will long in that bounce.
Or if price goes up from here then
94.5k,
if we go above that level and retest it
as a support, then I'm open in a long
there also, okay, until 100k. So, those
are my two trades for this end of the
year.
Again, expect a lot of volatility
because the gamma
is
finishing, is getting flushed, and there
is going to be a lot of more volatility
because the market makers don't need to
be hedging
their positions so much. All right, so
that's pretty much everything, guys.
Thank you so much for watching and I'll
see you again on Monday.